Gooden they have opportunity stops in the
quarterback here's Matthew barzell having
a career year assist per game and points per game
Brock Nelson another 20 goal season for him Corbat
shot nice blocker save there's Mayfield from
pelet gets it to zikas throws it in the corner
Martin behind the neet going to work C buck
in front he has it shot save Johansen good
opportunity for the fourth line shot in front
oh save Johanson that's Oliver walstrom the
youngster trying to get him going maybe Patrick W
can get more production under number 26 Here Comes
Holstrom now with pageo pageo has it drop pass
beautifully to Dobson Dobson looking throws it in
front Oliver walstrom on the doorstep number
26 his third goal of the year and the Islanders
under Patrick W strike first I just said that
Noah Dobson's got to shoot the puck he's got 52
points in 50 games now he's got 53 Puck comes
back to the point here we talked to Patrick W
about what's driving their offense using the
point getting bodies in front shooting pucks
Noah doson put this one at the net does it go off
for walstrom here H doesn't look what an honor
was to play against him and uh really coold what
a career he had it was just so neat before the
game to see you guys talking to one another shot
oh deflected in front COV with a shot that shot
hit something we'll see if it was an Islander
or if it was Stam Co first to the bench is COV
that likely means it's his 4 seconds after the
face off this is just another example why face
offs are so important in the offensive zone you
get it back and it make a great play SOS makes
a great play on the fake shot and KRA seeing
ey dog how about R actually actually Rish not
not them liberg falls down Nelson loses control
and Celli has little BG's back going to come the
great back passer by by Celli there doson and
pass in front Ang ball shot nice save Johanson
Sheri glovs it down chips it out and they don't
get many power play opportunities they don't
draw many penalties and the lightning don't take
many penalties here's Paul Mary oh what a what
a save by Johansson on Brock Nelson taking
a lot of penalties well if you want to drop
penalties you got to get the Pucket you got to
drive it into the scoring areas and make teams
draw penalties against you more Puck possession
is it going to equal more calls more penalties
for five on five team this year but they have a
good PK one timer what a save by johans that was
blistered by Nelson here's Horvat back to Brock
Nelson doson fakes the one- timer gets fine but
he gets it back barzel plays quick catch with
doson he gets it back to barzel down low Paul
Mary Corbat save by Johansson oh Horvat out to
take the face off against Steven stamp Co game
number one 52 for stamp Co two goals behind Keith
kachak on the alltime goal list down two long
Islanders the backand and the upper right hand
corner and off the face off the Islanders strike
quickly another important reason why the face
off was so important during the game some Mis
coverage lost coverage got players getting Puck
watching sure enough barzel is all along and
the young defenseman here gets Puck watching and
leaves the most dangerous guys on the Islanders
all in front of the net and as their number one
defenseman Here Comes Paul Mary now Kyle Palm
stops moves middle shot quite get to Johansson
pel pinching has it behind the net goes in front
score Kyle Paul Mary his 14th of the year and
the Islanders continue to pour it on in this
impressive impressive first period they lead
3 to one and I asked them I said you guys look
faster why is that they're playing as a fiveman
unit what that means that D got to get involved
right d jumps down the wall patience points makes
a great play Riley out in front the Paul Mary
Paul Mary buries it but in this leag it is very
very difficult to generate offense if you do not
attack probably should have given that a blast
straight paay by there just getting his stick
in the lane getting his body in the lane whatever
you can you know COV is going to fake but those
are big big plays J Celli now Celli has Hegel
to his left makes a shot save by croen rebound
score Brandon hegel's 18th goal of the year and
Tampa Bay the League's best power play puts one
on the board a long pass get trelli the time to
get to right there I think Roman is it Romanov I
got CAU kill the P you can't let guys get in
behind you sure enough he doesn't try makes
a great strong move to the uh to the net and
there's Hegel once again gets there in time
to keep it in but now it comes out and Watson has
it again up to liberg the young defenseman here's
Tyler M with some Wheels m in alone backand
Sav by soken a good one as pelic was beaten
by m but more importantly than anything for me in
my my opinion he is skating as well as I escaping
lastek rebound off the post Celli almost tied
the game coov Flo the shot Celli almost popped
it in penalty coming up rebounds wide by what a
move play as Steven Stam Co tried to prevent a
goal Tampa with some sustained pressure
they hadam end him for a while they get
the puck to the net but you know what you
got got to give Tampa credit they stay on
the puck they stay on the body there
great chances and here's it's also a
long game too you're going to get power
plays in the third period possibly with
the game on the line you want to establish
a shooting mentality it's so important by
shot Sikes Ryan poock third of the year it's
a 91 mph heater and the Islanders have their
two goal lead back but in this game we've got
three goals scor off defensive Zone break off
down off the face off and what a bomb that
was by Bak there Hammer does he can hammer
it he's missing the seven in front of the
seven in front of the six but he can bring
it barzel fishes it out with the toe of his
stick now tries to protect it almost Dre The
Penalty does it pelic has it he goes to Horvat
oh Horvat down to barzel Islanders are feeling
it they are feeling it and they score again B
Horvat 21st goal of the year and the Islanders
68 Seconds Apart beautiful screen great shot
Islanders are definitely feeling it right now
yeah and let's talk about barzal for a second
who's feeling it he's in on every play for the
Islanders driving offense he's isolating
defenses breaking them down finding open
guys and he's he's looking to get the number
down there's no reason you should leave Tampa
you wouldn't think so but uh you've been
there you seen a lot you cus in alone shot
score casy cus his sixth goal of the year is
the Islanders sixth goal of the game and they
lead 6 to2 Tampa they're definitely starting
to look a little tired and when you're tired
playing a back to to back you get sloppy
in your own Zone unfortunately with pass
unforced errors end up in the back of your net
everybody's getting involved on the Islanders
they're playing with poise they're playing
with grp doson keeps it in 14 and a half to
go and let's face it BCI this is a game that
the Islanders needed to come out and dictate
the pace I think it's a a team playing on a back
to back they're going to be here for a while as
we mentioned they got Calgary coming in this
weekend that's an afternoon game this Saturday
on fans a 1:00 start shot Hegel roken can find
it and then Glen Denny almost poked that over
him for the short-handed goal that seemed like
training camp practices right away he's going
to have more time to practice in the coming weeks
has another two points he's in the bank we got to
come out some more games out here this building is
awesome impressive win by the New York Islanders